the lawyer for adult film star stormy
Daniels says his client should be free
to give her account of her relationship
with Donald Trump that is a contention
of a new lawsuit filed yesterday in Los
Angeles Superior Court it says that a
nondisclosure agreement signed by
Daniel's whose real name is Stephanie
Clifford is legally null and void the
suit alleges that since mr. Trump
himself never signed the agreement
Daniel should be free to discuss her
quote intimate relationship with mr.
Trump back in 2006 it lasted until 2007
we reached out to the White House a
Trump organization and mr. Trump's
lawyer that's Michael Cohen for comment
on this suit would have not yet received
a response stormy Daniels has a new
attorney his name is Michael avenatti
and he joins us at the table Michael
thank you for joining us this morning
good morning first before we talk about
the lawsuit why does someone who had a
consensual relationship allegedly with
Donald Trump back in the day want to
discuss it
most people who engaged in an
extramarital affair aren't out there
saying I want to tell you what happened
why does she want to tell this story
well I think at this point she wants to
tell her story because there's so much
misinformation out there and so much
misinformation that's been spread by mr.
Cohen and others quite honestly over the
last six weeks relating to what happened
the circumstances of the agreement the
circumstances of the payment and she
wants to set the record straight she
wants to be heard and she wants to tell
the public the true facts of what
happened here does she want a profit
from selling her story absolutely not
she will not be seeking any money for
her story in any way I don't know
whether she's going to ultimately seek
payment or not what I do know is she
wants the public to know the truth
and she wants to be free of these
agreements the name listed on the NDA or
non-disclosure agreement is David
Dennison is that an alias for president
Donald Trump yes how do we know that
well I I know it and I'm making that
assertion and if I'm false let mr.
Kohinoor mr. Trump come forward
immediately and claim that in fact it's
not an alias for Donald Trump it most
certainly is an alias for Donald Trump
and to conclude otherwise you would have
to conclude that mr. Cohen who
represented mr. Trump at the time
admitted to the hundred and thirty
thousand dollar payment made the payment
on behalf of some other party some other
individual that went by that alias well
he says that this is a danger to the
president he excuse me that candidate
Trump he took care of it with his own
money and that that mr. Trump knew
nothing about it I think it is
completely uncredible to assert that in
fact that happened you would have to
conclude that mr. Cohen was operating in
on his own mr. Trump knew nothing about
it and in fact the drafted agreement had
a place for mr. Trump to sign multiple
places the idea that somehow mr. Trump
never knew anything about it I just
think it strains credibility okay help
me understand is this a publicity Skype
or do you really think that you can get
this NDA thrown out and why no this
isn't a publicity stunt I want to be
wasting my time or staking my reputation
on it if it was a publicity stunt we
believe the NDA will be tossed out we
believe that it will show that mr. Trump
never signed either document and
therefore she's free to tell her story
doesn't the NDA say this Michael that
either David Dennison David Dennison
which you say is Donald Trump or his
attorney has to sign it and the attorney
did sign it so that that makes the NDA
valid no in fact first of all his
attorney did not sign on his behalf his
attorney signed on behalf of the entity
that was created in order to funnel the
payment to miss Daniels first of all and
second of all mr. Trump was obligated to
sign the agreements in order for them to
be legally binding this is no longer mr.
Trump this is now president Trump when a
judge looks at this they're gonna weigh
the damage done to your client versus
the damage that could be done to a
president interrupting and president's
time also damaging the office so a judge
says to you why is your clients desire
to profit from her story more important
than the country's business well first
of all my client doesn't have a desire
to profit from her story you asked me
about that earlier and I answered those
questions that's number one number two I
don't think we're talking about
interrupting the presidency of the
United States at all these are very
simple questions did he sign the
agreement did he know about the
agreement the payment etc it doesn't
take long to answer those questions in
fact you can certainly answer them in
less than 140 carry 130,000 dollars why
did she tell you she was
130000 well I'm not gonna get into the
details about communications that I've
had with my client because that's
privileged of course but what I will
tell you is that there was obviously a
reason for the payment of one hundred
and thirty thousand dollars and we
assert it was in an effort to silence
her
well the NDA says that prior to signing
the agreement that Daniels came into
confidential information including but
not limited to still images and/or text
messages authored by or relating to didi
who you say is Donald Trump does she
have photos or text messages that prove
the affair we're not going to answer
that question as of this morning but
there is additional information that
exists out there
there is certainly additional
information relating to this NDA the
circumstances and their relationship
that I'm confident will be forthcoming
and also Michael Cohen says he paid that
hunt that's mr. Trump's attorney says he
paid that hundred and thirty thousand
dollars out of his own pocket do you
have information to suggest that that
payment came from somewhere else we do
but we're not in a position to disclose
it quite yet meaning that that money was
not from Michael Cohen the attorneys own
sort of source of funds that it was from
someone else I think I've commented
enough on that as of this morning he
heard from the White House or the from
the White House or Michael Cohen himself
we have not heard yet but again this can
be clarified pretty easily did mr. Trump
now president Trump sign these documents
did he know about the negotiation and
the payment it's very very simple
was it a consensual relationship can you
say that absolutely all right thank you
Michael thank you